i'm asking you this question
assuming everybody's healthy okay so
we're not at factoring anyone who's
injured right now let's say the playoffs
come everyone's healthy
at 100 who do you got to win the ring
the nets the nets yep hands down hands
down
yeah even against the lakers i just
don't see someone beating
kyrie irving kd james harden blake
griffin in a
in a all every game series
harris state they're just a really good
team i just think i think the only thing
that they might
be that might they might be lacking is
who's going to guard
a.d yeah no for sure and then obviously
they need to get along
that you know yeah they gotta get along
all three haven't really been healthy
for that
they all three of them haven't played
together at once like i i think maybe it
was like six games maybe
only a few games so i mean but off
talent though you you know
two guys can have a bag i just don't
know how you can outscore the nets
like they don't even i look at it like
they don't even gotta [ __ ] play
defense
like you gotta outscore them facts like
someone's gonna be open
i got them